foreign
we have Adam in Phoenix hey Adam welcome
to the show
hello how are you we are doing great
so um
my wife and I we have quite a bit of
debt
um and so I was wondering how we should
start working through that you have
about 150 in car loans and about 280 in
student loans 115 and car loans
uh one five zero 150 in carlands okay
about 75 on each okay and uh been about
280 in student loans okay
um
so when I called in with the screener I
said we have quite a bit in home equity
so I was curious
um is that something that would be on
the table the seller house and just
basically wipe it all out one fail swoop
or actually work our way through that
yeah it's a good that's a a good
question
um Adam how much you guys make a year
uh net combines about 330. okay
and for the home how much do you how
much do you owe on it how much is left
on the mortgage
um about 385. okay and how much would it
sell for
um probably near eight
okay and why do you have a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in cars
I guess you make 330. so I guess that
works what kind of cars do you all Drive
uh well you guys the BMW is one of them
yeah and uh another one is a newer truck
yeah I mean I expect nice cars yeah if
you're making 330 yeah well for yeah 150
000 hopefully you're not saying a Honda
Civic like I would I would like assume I
mean I would assume like yeah but it
goes something it makes that cool Noise
Okay so Adam
um do you guys have any money in savings
do you have any cash
yeah we do how much you have um
all right right now we have about 10
we're waiting on
um
about 30
000 to come in and what do you what is
it what do you mean waiting on what does
that mean
uh for for an invoice oh okay okay like
so that'll be 30 000 cash to you
correct okay
um no you don't need to sell so no you
don't need to sell your house
um I can kind of just dive into it
because you guys how old are you guys
Adam
um I am 41 and my wife is 32. okay do
you guys have kids
yes one one kid okay before HS is that
you're the richest broke guy I've talked
to in a while
does that ring true
I guess you make way too much money to
be this broke
I I agree with you 100 yeah okay so Adam
Rachel I'll give you the path
so I need like I need you to like
realize because here's the deal yeah you
could sell your home
take four hundred thousand dollars wipe
this all clean but Adam and his wife are
Gonna Keep on Living their life the way
they have there's gonna be no change in
this process and mathematically you
don't need to sell your house you guys
just need to get your crap together and
you would also sell your house to pay
off two degrees depreciating assets yeah
that doesn't make any sense man yeah no
no so I would I would stay put in the
home
and you guys Adam I'm like I there's
something about you all at this point
that I'm like I want you to feel a level
of sacrifice so with this debt I mean
because you have 280 in student loans
you can't afford these cars at them so
I'm selling them I mean I'm I'm gonna
get rid of them use some of this 10
grand to buy you know or wait for the 30
grand to come in spend 15 grand on two
cars and again they're not going to be
BMWs in a nice truck like you're going
to have a lifestyle shock factor to you
all but I think you kind of need it Adam
you guys make a lot of money
you have a lot of debts and something
has to change your formula is not
working would you agree
I agree 100 yeah so I mean I think
that's kind of been the realization
um yeah
and y'all as of recently you know yeah
and I'm like man you know you're 41 and
I know we can't go back in time there's
a part of me wish that you were 25 so
I'd be like clean this up and you're
like gonna go so at 41 it's even that
much more urgent to be like Adam you
guys make insane money like you could do
really well but if you keep living like
this you're not going to like you work
too hard and you've worked too hard
to have nothing to have 280 in student
loan debt and a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in cars like
like the I I wouldn't want to make three
you know 3 30 and that be my life right
so like there has to be something that
majorly changes so if I woke up in your
shoes Adam
I would sit down and I would say all
right we're in Phoenix we make 380. how
do we live on 75 Grands next year like
let's just count and that's still a
really great salary there's a lot of
people that wish they made 75 000 like
what if we just took majority of our
income sold the cars paid off the debt I
mean all this could be turned around in
a year Adam and you still have your
house with your equity
yeah
I agree and um personally I've been
looking at ways to maybe even increase
our income
you can't I just think y'all freaking
need to cut your lifestyle you can't be
just like hanging out going on vacation
all the time it's just also just
remember for a year for a year that's
all you got to do I wouldn't up your
income you guys have an amazing income I
think it's your lifestyle if we look at
this right now it's uncomfortable is
that 18 months you go from making 3 30
and owing three to four hundred thousand
to yeah owing nobody anything is 30
grand coming in too remember that half a
million dollars in equity in your house
like you you flip things around so fast
so fast you all could be in a completely
somewhere in 48 months like the whole
thing rolls over but you just gotta say
never do it you just gotta do it
gotcha
all right um I was trying to get
quasi-familiar with your guys's baby
steps and whatnot um okay so so
um oh this is gonna make you real
uncomfortable man that's gonna be so
well what it is Adam I mean like
honestly I'm like I would and and the
baby steps is this I'm like I I would
it's a thousand dollar emergency fund so
you so you freed up in our math right
now you freed up nine Grands from the 10
grand that you have let's say the the 30
comes in you got 39 Grand to use okay
you sell your cars
I wonder how much I wonder if you Kelly
Blue booked on what you would do because
you're going to lose money on them
you're going to owe some money probably
on it
um get some beaters and then with your
income again I'm like golly and yeah in
12 months Adam you're paying off your
debt smallest to largest but I would get
rid of the cars and so the only debt you
have left is that 280 and the student
loans and you guys start just throwing
everything at it everything and yeah and
working extra I mean I kind of was like
no you don't need your income yeah sure
work actually like do whatever you guys
can to get out of the 280 as fast as
possible but if I were you all if I woke
up in your shoes the first place I'm
cutting is lifestyle which is the most
painful and not in the most not fun
right you've been y'all been going out
to eat going on vacations with friends I
mean I can only imagine your lifestyle
and I bet it's great and so fun but
nothing oh we have and I'm not going to
deny that at all I mean yeah we work so
hard to get to that point in life yeah
and then
my my wife graduated and then we were
like well we're here let's enjoy it and
that's normal
you're not crazy yeah that that is
normal it's all of us but also your
results are normal and normal is broke
right so you're waking up to the fact
like oh my gosh we're just like
everybody else everything looks great
but we literally don't have an I mean we
don't have much of a net worth even
though we make 330 000 a year you know
so it's that really simple mindset but
Adam
um yeah stay on the line and I'm Gonna
Give You Total Money Makeover it's one
of our best-selling books when it comes
to just the baby steps you can read it
in a night it's a really easy read but
walk through this process with your wife
because again I'm so encouraged by your
numbers you guys could have an insane
life that's all yours and not tied to
the bank anymore but you guys have to
make that decision thanks for the call
this is the Ramsey Show